the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so you know basically the last few weeks
we've been doing derivatives now we're
going to do integrals
so
okay so more precisely we're going to be
talking about double integrals
okay so just to motivate the notion let
me just remind you that when you have a
function of one variable say f of X and
if you take its integral from say A to B
of f of X DX
well that corresponds to the area below
the graph of F over the interval from A
to B okay so the picture is something
like have a you have B you have the
graph of f and then what the integral
measures is the area of this region and
when we say the area of this region of
course if F is positive that's what
happens if F is negative then we count
negatively the area below the x-axis so
now when you have a function of two
variables then you can try to do the
same thing namely you can plot its graph
its class will be a surface in space and
then we can try to look for the volume
below the graph and that's what we will
call the double integral of a function
over a certain region
okay so let's say that we have a
function of two variables x and y then
we look at the volume that's below the
graph z equals f of X Y okay so it's a
picture for what this means I have a
function of x and y I can draw its graph
the graph will be you know the surface
with equation Z equals f of X and y and
well I have to decide where I will
integrate the function so for that I
will choose some agent in the XY plane
and they will integrate the function on
that vision so it's over a region R in
the XY plane they have this region R and
I look at the piece of the graph that is
above this region and we'll try to
compute the volume of this solid here
that's what the double integral will
measure so we'll call that the double
integral over the region R of F of XY da
and I will have to explain what the
notation means
so da here stands for a piece of area a
stands for area and well the double
integral so that's why we have two
integral signs and we'll have to
indicate somehow the region over which
were integrating okay we'll come up with
more concrete notations when we see how
to actually compute these things but
that's the basic definition okay so
actually how do well I mean that's not
really much of a definition yet how do
we actually
you know define this rigorously well
remember of a integral in one variable
you probably saw a definition where you
take your interval from A to B and you
cut it into little pieces and then for
each little piece you take the value of
a function and you multiply by the width
of a piece that gives you a rectangular
slice and then you sum all of these
rectangular slices together so here
we'll do the same thing okay so well let
me put a picture up and explain what it
does so we are going to cut our region
into little pieces say little rectangle
sides with anything we want and then for
each piece with a small area Delta a
will take the area Delta a times the
value of a function in there that will
give us the volume of a small box that
sits under the graph and then we'll add
all these boxes together that gives us
an estimate of a volume and then to get
actually the integral the integral will
be defined as a limit as we subdivide
into smaller and smaller boxes and with
some more pieces okay
so actually what we do oh I still have a
I still have a board here
so the actual definition involves
cutting our into small pieces of area
let's call Delta a maybe Delta a I the
area of the I've piece and then okay so
maybe in the XY plane we have our pigeon
and we'll cut it may be using some grade
okay and then we'll have each small
piece each small piece will have our
Delta a made I I and it will be at some
point let's call it X I Y I Y I X I and
then we'll consider the sum over all the
pieces of F at that point X I Y I times
the area of a small piece so what that
corresponds to in the three-dimensional
picture is just I sum the volumes of all
of these little columns that set under
the graph okay and then
so what I do is actually I take the
limit as first you know the size of the
pieces tends to zero so I have more and
more smaller and smaller pieces and that
gives me the double integral it's not a
very good sentence but whatever so okay
so that's the definition of course we'll
have to see how to compute it we don't
actually compute it you know when you
compute an integral in single variable
calculus you don't do that you don't cut
into little pieces and some of the
pieces together you've learned how to
integrate functions using various
formulas and similarly here we'll learn
how to actually compute these things
without doing that cutting into small
pieces but okay any questions first
about the concept or what the definition
is
yes
well so we'll have to learn which takes
work and how exactly that so what we'll
do actually is we reduce the calculation
of a double integral to two calculations
of single integrals and so for these
certainly all the tricks you've learned
in single variable calculus will come in
handy okay so yes that's a strong signal
by the way that if you've forgotten
everything about single variable
calculus now might be a good time to
actually brush up on you know integrals
you know the usual integrals and the
usual sub different substitution tricks
and easy to rig in particular this will
be very useful okay so yes so how do we
compute these things that's what we have
to come up with and well you know going
back to what we did with derivatives to
understand variations of functions and
derivatives what we did was really we
took slices parallel to an axis or
another one so in fact here the key is
also the same so what we're going to do
is instead of cutting into a lot of
small boxes like that and summing
completely at random will actually
somehow scan our region scan for our
region by parallel planes okay so let me
put up actually a slightly different
picture up here so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take planes say in this
picture up parallel to the Y Z plane
I'll take a moving plane that scans from
the back to the front or from the front
to the back so that means you know I set
the value of x 0 of X and I look at the
slice x equals x0 and then I will do
that for all values of x 0 so now in
each slice well I get what looks a lot
like a single variable integral ok and
that integral will tell me what is the
area in this well I guess was supposed
to be green but it all comes as black so
let's save a black shaded slice and then
when I add all of these areas together
as the value of exchanges I will get the
volume let me try to explain that in
so to compute this integral what we do
is actually we take slices so let's
consider let's call s of X the area of a
slice so well by a by a plane parallel
to the Y Z plane okay so on the picture
s of X is just the area of this thing in
the in the vertical wall now if you sum
all of these well let's see why does
that work so if you take the region
between two parallel slices that are
very close to each other what's the
volume between these two things
well it's essentially s of x times the
thickness of this very thin slice and
the thickness would be Delta X or DX if
you take a limit with more and more
slices okay so that the volume will be
the integral of s of X DX on well what's
the range for X well we would have to
start at the very lowest value of x that
ever happened in our region and we'd
have to go all the way to the very
largest value of X okay from the very
far back to the very front so on this
picture
we'd probably start you know over here
at the back and we'd end over here at
the front
so let me just say from you know the
minimum X to the maximum X and now how
do we find as of X well s of X will be
actually again an integral but now it's
an integral of a variable Y because when
we look at this slice what changes from
left to right is Y so let me actually
write that down for a given X the area s
of X we can compute as an integral of f
of X Y dy
okay well now X is a constant and Y will
be the variable of integration without
what's the range for y well it's from
you know the leftmost point here to the
rightmost point here on the given slice
so there's a big catch here that's a
very important thing to remember what is
the range of integration the range of
integration for Y depends actually on X
see if I took a slice if I take this
slice that's pictured on that diagram
then the range for Y goes all the way
from the very left to the very right but
if I take a slice let's say you have a
very fond then in fact only a very small
segment of it will be in my region so
the range of values for Y will be much
less let me actually draw to the picture
for that so remember we fix X and we
value sorry so we fix a value of x okay
and for a given value of x what we'll do
is we'll slice our graph by this plane
parallel to the Y Z plane so now imagine
the graph is sitting above it and that's
the region R I have the region R and I'm
I have the graph of a function above
this region R
and I'm trying to find the area between
this segment and the graph above it in
this vertical plane well to do that I
have to integrate from y from y going
from here to here right I want the area
of a piece that sits above this red
segment and so in particular the
endpoints the extreme values for Y
depend on X you could see if I slice
here instead well my bounds for y will
be smaller okay so now if I put the two
things together what I will get is
actually a formula where I have to
integrate over X and integral of my
okay and so this is called an iterated
integral because we iterate twice the
process of taking an integral
okay so again what's important to
realize here I mean I'm going to say
that several times over the next few
days but that's because it's the single
most important thing to remember about
double integrals the bounds here are
just going to be numbers okay because
the question that I'm asking myself here
is what is the first value of x by which
and I want to slice and what is the last
value of x you know which range of X do
I want to look at to take my right
slices and the answer is I would go all
the way from here that's my first slice
to somewhere here
that's my last slice for any value in
between vs I will have some some height
segments and I will in want to integrate
over that on the other hand here the
bounds will depend on the outer variable
X because if I fix a value of X what the
values of Y will be depends on X
internal okay so I think we should do
lots of examples to convince ourselves
you know and see how it works
sorry
yeah it's called an iterated integral
because first we integrate about Y and
then we integrate again over X okay so
we can do that well I mean Y depends on
X or X depends
no actually x and y vary independently
of each other inside here what what is
more complicated is how the bounds on Y
depends on X but actually you could also
do it the other way around first
integrate over X and then over Y and
then the bounds for X would depend on Y
we will see that on an example yes
so for y i'm using the range of values
for y that corresponds to the given
value of x okay i mean remember this is
just like a plot in the xy-plane above
that we have the graph maybe I should
draw a picture here instead for a given
value of x so that's a given slice I
have a range of values for y that is
from you know the specter it's the
leftmost point on that slice to the
rightmost point on that slice so where I
start and where I stop depends on the
value of x does that make sense okay
okay
no more questions no okay
so let's do a first example
so let's say that we want to integrate
the function 1 minus X square minus y
squared of the region defined by X
between 0 & 1 and y between 0 & 1 so
what does that mean geometrically well Z
equals 1 minus X square minus y squared
and it's a variation and you know
something I think actually we've plotted
that one right when we that was our
first example of a function of two
variables possibly and so we saw that
the graph is this paraboloid pointing
downwards it's what you get by taking
the parabola hyperbola and rotating it
and now what we're asking is what is the
volume between the paraboloid and the
xy-plane over the square of side 1 in
the xy-plane
x and y between 0 & 1 okay so what we'll
do is we'll so see here I've try to
represent the square and we'll just sum
the areas of the slices as say X varies
from 0 to 1 and here of course setting
upper bounds will be easy because no
matter what X I take Y still goes from 0
to 1
see it's easiest to do double integrals
when the region is just a rectangle in
the XY plane because then you don't have
to worry too much about what are the
ranges okay so let's do it
well that would be
the integral from zero to one of the
integral from 0 to 1 of 1 minus X square
minus y squared dy DX okay so I'm
dropping the parentheses but if you
still want to see them I'm going to put
them in it very thin so as you see what
it means but actually the convention is
we won't put these parentheses in vari
anymore okay so what this means is first
I will integrate 1 minus X square minus
y squared over Y ranging from 0 to 1
with X held fixed so what that
represents is the area in this slice so
see here actually I've drawn well what
happens is actually the function takes
positive and negative values so in fact
I will be counting positively this part
of the ayah and I will be counting
negatively this part of the area I mean
as usual when I do an integral so what I
will do to evaluate this I will first do
what's called the inner integral so to
do the inner integral well it's pretty
easy how do i integrate this well
becomes so what's the integral of 1 it's
why just me anything to remember is
we're integrating with respect to Y
naught to X ok the integral of x squared
is x squared times y and the integral of
Y squared is y cubed over 3 ok and when
we plug in the bounds which are 0 and 1
in this case and so when you plug y
equals 1 you will get 1 minus x squared
minus 1/3 minus well for y equals 0 you
get 0 0 0 so nothing changes because
you're left with 2/3 minus x squared
okay and that's a function of X only
here you shouldn't see any wise anymore
because Y it was your integration
variable but you still have X you still
have X because the area of this shaded
slice depends of course on the value of
X
and so now the second thing to do is to
do the outer integral so now we
integrate from 0 to 1 what we got which
is 2/3 minus x squared DX okay and we
know how to compute that because that
integrates to 2/3 X minus 1/3 X cubed
between 0 and 1 and I let you do the
computation you will find it's 1/3 ok so
that's the final answer so that's the
general pattern see we when we have a
double integral to compute first we want
to set it up carefully we want to find
what will be the bounds in x and y and
here that was actually pretty easy
because our region was very simple then
we want to compute the inner integral
and when we compute the outer integral
and that's it
ok any questions at this point
okay so by the way we started with a da
in the notation right here we had da and
that somehow became a dy/dx okay so the
a became dy/dx because when we do the
eyetality integral this way what we are
actually doing is that we are slicing
our region into small rectangles okay
now what's the area of this small
rectangle here well it's the product of
its width times its height so that's
Delta x times Delta Y okay so Delta a
equals Delta X Delta Y became so
actually it's not just becomes it's very
equal
for the small rectangles for now it
became dy/dx and not DX dy well that's a
question of in which order we do the
eyetality integral it's up to us to
decide whether we're going to integrate
X first then Y or Y first then X but as
we'll see very soon that is an important
decision when it comes to setting up the
bounds of integration here it doesn't
matter but in general we have to be very
careful about in which order we'll do
things yes will always work so yeah it
well in principle it always works both
ways sometimes it will be that you know
because the region has a strange shape
you can actually set it up more easily
one way than the other sometimes it will
also be that the function here you
actually know how to integrate in one
way that not the other so the theory is
that it should work both ways in
practice one of the two calculations may
be much harder
okay
let's do another example let's say that
what I wanted to know was you know not
actually what I computed namely the
volume below the paraboloid but also the
negative of some part that you know in
the corner towards me but let's say when
what I wanted was just the volume
between the paraboloid
and the XY plane so looking only at the
part of it that sits above the XY plane
so that means instead of integrating
over the entire square of size one I
should just integrate over the quarter
disk right I should stop integrating
where my power below it hits the XY
plane so let me draw another picture so
let's say I wanted to integrate actually
so let's call this example - sorry so
it's the same thing we're going to do
the same function but over a different
region and the region will just be now
this plot or disk here okay so maybe I
should the whole picture in the xy-plane
that's my new original okay so in
principle it will be the same integral
but what changes is the bounds why do
the bounds change
well the bounds change because now if I
set if I fix some value of x then I will
want to integrate this part of a slice
that's above the XY plane and I don't
want to take this part that's actually
outside of my disk so I should stop
integrating over Y when y which is this
value here on that picture here on this
picture it tells me for a fixed value of
x the range of values for y should go
only from here to here so that's from
here to less than one okay so for given
X the range of Y is well so what's the
lowest value of y we want to look at
it's still 0 on y equals 0 - what's the
value of y here well I have to solve in
the equation of the circle okay
so if I'm here this is X square plus y
square equals 1 that means Y is square
root of 1 minus x squared
so I will integrate from y equals zero
to y equals square root of one minus x
squared and now you see how the bound
for y will depend on the value of x okay
so when i erase I will let you think
about what is the bound for X now it's a
trick question
okay so I claim that what we'll do
so we'll write this as an iterated
integral first dy then DX and we said
for a fixed value of x the range for y
is from zero to square root of one minus
x squared what about the range for X
well the range for X should just be
numbers okay remember the question I
have to ask now is if I look at all of
these yellow slices which one is the
first one that I want to consider which
one is the last one that I want to
consider so the smallest value of x that
I want to consider is zero again and
then I will have there I will actually
have a pretty big slice and I will get
smaller and smaller and smaller slices
and it stops I have to stop when x
equals one afterwards there's nothing
else to integrate so X goes from zero to
one
okay and now see how in the inner
integral of bounds depend on X in the
outer one you just get numbers because
the questions that you have to ask to
set up this one and set up that one are
different here the question is if I fix
a given X if I look at a given slice
what's the range for y here the question
is what's the first slice what is the
last slice does that make sense everyone
happy with that okay very good
so now how do we compute that well we do
the inner integral so that's integral
from zero to square root of 1 minus x
squared of 1 minus X square minus y
squared dy and well that integrates to y
minus x squared y minus y cubed away
from 0 to square root of 1 minus x
squared and then that becomes well root
of 1 minus x squared minus x squared
root of 1 minus x squared minus y minus
x squared to the three-halves over 3 and
actually if you look at it for long
enough see this is 1 minus x squared
times square root of 1 minus x squared
so actually that's also so in fact that
simplifies to 2/3 of 1 minus x squared
to the three-halves okay let me we do
that maybe slightly differently this was
1 minus x squared times y so
one minus x squared times y becomes
Sequeira root of one minus x squared
oops x squared minus y cubed off a and
then when I take Y pour 0 I get 0 so I
don't subtract anything ok so now you
see this is 1 minus x squared to the
three-halves minus 1/3 of it so you're
left with 2/3 okay so that's the inner
integral the outer integral is integral
from 0 to 1 of 2/3 of 1 minus x squared
to the three-halves DX and well I let
you see if you remember single bible
integrals by trying to figure out how
this actually comes out to be the PI
over 2 or PI over 8 to take its PI over
8
hmm
okay well I guess we have to do it then
I've also been on my notes but it's not
very clear okay so how do we compute
this week well we have to do trig
substitution that's the only way I know
to compute an integral like that
okay so we'll set X equal sine theta and
then square root of 1 minus x squared
will be cosine theta we're using sine
square plus cosine square equals 1
and so that will become so 2/3 when it's
2/3 1 minus x squared to the
three-halves becomes cosine cubed theta
DX well sine if X is sine theta then DX
is cosine theta D theta so that's cosine
theta D theta and well if you do things
some additions the way I do them then
you should worry about the bounds for
theta which will be 0 to PI over 2 or
you can you know also just plug in the
bounds at the end so now you have the
2/3 times the integral from 0 to PI over
2 of cosine to the 4 theta D theta and
how do you integrate that well you have
to use double angle formulas ok so
cosine to the 4 remember cosine square
theta is 1 plus cosine 2 theta over 2
and we want the square of it
and so that will give us of well we'll
have socially 1/4 plus 1/2 cosine 2
theta plus 1/4 cosine square 2 theta
d-theta
and how will you handle this guy while
using again the double angle formula
okay so it's getting slightly nasty so
but I don't know any simpler solution
except for one simpler solution which is
you have a table of integrals of this
form inside the notes yes
no I don't think so because if you take
1/2 times cosine 1/2 times 2 you will
still have a half okay so if you do
again the double angle formula I think
I'm not going to bother to do it I claim
you will get at the end PI over 8
because I say so
so okay so exercise continue calculating
and get PI over eight okay
now what does this show us well this
shows us actually that this is probably
not the right way to do this okay the
right way to do this will be to
integrate it in polar coordinates and
that's why we will learn how to do
tomorrow okay so we'll actually see how
to do it with much less trig
so that will be easier in polar
coordinates so we'll see that tomorrow
ok so but you know we're almost there I
mean here you just use the double angle
again and then you can get it and it's
it's pretty straightforward ok so one
thing that's kind of interesting to know
is we can exchange the order of
integration so if we have an integral
given to us in the order dy DX we can
switch it to DX dy but we have to be
extremely careful with the bounds so you
certainly cannot just swap the bounds of
the inner and outer because where you
would end up you know having this square
root of 1 minus X square on the outside
and you would never get a number out of
that so that cannot work it's more
complicated than that ok so well here's
a first baby example certainly if I do
integral from 0 to 1 integral from 0 to
2 DX dy I can there I can certainly
switch 4 bounds without thinking too
much what's the reason for that well the
reason for that is you know this
corresponds in both cases to integrating
X from 0 to 2 and Y from 0 to 1
it's a rectangle so if I slice it this
way you see that Y goes from 0 to 1 for
any X between 0 and 2 it's this game if
I slice it that way then X goes from 0
to 2 for any value of y between 0 1 1
and it's this one so here it works but
in general I have to draw a picture of
my region and see how the slices look
like both ways ok so let's do a more
interesting one
let's say that I want to compute
integral from 0 to 1 of integral from x
2 square root of x of e to the y of my
dy/dx so why did I choose this guy I
chose this guy because as far as I can
tell there's no way to integrate e to
the Y over Y so this is an integral that
you cannot compute this way so it's a
good example for why this can be useful
so if you do it this way you're stuck
immediately so instead we'll try to
switch the order but to switch the order
we have to understand what do these
bounds mean okay so let's draw a picture
of the region well what we are saying is
y goes from y equals x to y equal square
root of x well let's draw y equals x and
y equals square root of x well maybe I
should actually put this here y equals x
to y equals square root of x ok and so I
will go for each value of x I will go
from y equals x to y equals square root
of x they will do that for values of x
that go from x equals 0 to x equals 1
which happens to be exactly where these
things intersect so my region will
consist of all this ok so now if I want
to do it the other way around I have to
decompose my region the other way around
I have to so my goal now is to verify
this is an integral well it's still the
same function it's still e to the Y over
Y but now I want to integrate DX dy so
how do i integrate over X well I fix a
value of y and for that value of y
what's the range for X well the range
for X is from here
- here ok what's the value of x here
let's start with the easy one this is x
equals y what about this one it's x
equals x equals y squared ok so X goes
from y squared to Y and then what about
Y well I have to start at the bottom of
my region that's y equals 0 to the top
which is at y equals 1 so Y goes from 0
to 1 so see switching the bounds is not
completely obvious then that took a
little bit of work but now that we've
done that well just to see how it goes
it's actually going to be much easier to
integrate because in our integral well
what's the integral of e to the Y over Y
with respect to X just that times X
right from x equals I squared to Y so
that will be well if I plug x equals y I
will get e to the Y minus if i plug x
equals y squared I will get e to the Y
over Y times y squared e to the Y times
y ok so now if I do the outer integral I
will have the integral from 0 to 1 of e
to the Y minus y e to the Y dy and that
one actually is a little bit easier so
we know how to integrate e to the Y we
don't quite know how to integrate Y e to
the Y but let's try so let's see what's
the derivative of Y a to the Y well dry
the product whole that's 1 times e to
the y plus y times the derivative of e
to the Y is y e to the Y so if we do ok
let's put a minus sign in front
well that's almost what we want except
we have a minus e to the Y instead of a
plus e to the Y so we need to add to e
to the Y and I claim that the
antiderivative okay if you got lost you
can also do it by integrating by parts
by taking the derivative of Y and
integrating this guy oh but you know
that works just you know your first
guess would be maybe less i minus y e to
the y take the derivative of that
compare see what you need to do to fix
so if you take that between 0 and 1 you
will eventually get a minus 2
okay so tomorrow we are going to see how
to do double integrals in polar
coordinates and also applications of
double integrals how to use them for
interesting things